now explain all of this with regard to
the New York Jets I desperately want to
buy them Larry you do yes I do you know
look I'll tell you the truth when I came
to America in in Queens and in Dover I
couldn't speak English barely speaking
any English and they were playing
football and my friend Eric Kapur he's
like what team do you like and I was
literally like that kid that didn't
speak English I was like you know I
probably did one of those he says you're
a Jets fan and so I went home I was like
I'm a Jets fan it was my first kite it
was my first American thing so they all
had jet jerseys we would play and I
wanted a jet jersey because I fell in
love with the Jets but we were poor we
couldn't afford stuff like that it's not
what immigrants do you know go out and
buy a $30 Jets Jersey so my mom knitted
me wanted she made it and the back of
this has my favorite number number five
and says Gary and I literally wore it
every day and it's my prized possession
it's literally my prized possession it
just symbolizes where we came from which
was very very very humble beginnings and
I've created a fairy tale in my mind
somewhere around second or third grade
that I was going to go from not being
able to afford a Jersey to owning the
whole damn thing the quest to buy the
Jets is my happiness you know I've
always wondered why I always said I
would buy the Jets and I wonder how much
all that has to do with it it's a big
deal to me it's like that's a big deal